le paysage est digne d'une carte postale
la rencontre et tout ce qui a de plus
solonelle mais l'objet des discussions
contraste avec le décor la situation
sécuritaire se dégrade
et nous ne pouvons pas le laisser le
luxe de le laisser perdu le Premier
ministre désigné d'Haïti Ariel Henry
compte en partie sur le Canada pour
élaborer des solutions à la crise qui
perdure depuis 18 mois dans son pays
que ça continue d'être extrêmement
difficile pour la papaye juste un truc
dont répond présent il y aura de l'aide
à court terme d'abord Ottawa annonce
12,3 millions de dollars supplémentaires
en aide humanitaire et un autre 10
millions pour soutenir les actions de
l'office de migration de l'ONU à la
frontière d'Haïti et de la République
Dominicaine puis sur le plan de la
sécurité il faut alimenter les capacités
de la Police nationale d'Haïti pour
qu'elle prenne le dessus sur les gains
et la marine royale canadienne est aussi
appelée en renfort dans les prochaines
semaines des navires mettront le cap sur
les Caraïbes pour faire de la
surveillance au large des côtes
haïtiennes d'avoir une présence maritime
dans la baie va certainement dissuader
les gangs d'utiliser l'océan ou la mer
pour continuer leur leurs efforts de
violence contre et de contrôle du peuple
haïtien et Justin Trudeau annonce de
nouvelles sanctions contre deux membres
de l'élite et haïtienne soupçonnées de
financer les gains criminelles mais pour
ce qui est de déploiement militaire ou
d'une force d'intervention
internationale juste être Rudo veut un
engagement de la partie haïtienne que
cela mènera à des élections
démocratiques mais on ne met pas
d'échéancier concret dessus on a besoin
de stabilité et de consensus politiques
pour permettre à une restauration de
sécurité et d'ordre dans le passé payé
étranger ont été assez ronds afin des
interventions en Haïti mais cette
fois-ci tout le monde est prudent pour
cette ancienne ambassadeur du Canada en
Haïti cette fois les Haïtiens devront
faire preuve de volonté et de cohésion
s'ils veulent qu'une force
internationale se met en place je pense
qu'avec
l'appui d'une force multinationale ou
une autre manière d'accompagner ici on
pourrait arriver à quelque chose juste
intrudo n'hésite donc pas à s'engager à
aider à Haïti mais il hésite sur la
façon de le faire et la forme que
pourrait prendre cette aide dépendra en
grande partie des efforts déployés par
les Haïtiens eux-mêmes pour restaurer la
démocratie ici Valérie gamacher Obama